I am ok so hello and welcome to this
video I wasn't sure if it actually is on
but I think it is so let's jump into
that hourly I could do the Blitz arena I
don't think ever did dad this is Mary
more relaxed yeah let's do that down a
five-minute thing join the bouzouki I
actually have two to two and a half
minutes that's not bad ok so thanks for
the feedback on the video that I posted
yesterday it seemed like things were
mostly fine so I'm continuing to do
those I actually tried today during the
yeah some some time afternoon but I
decided to scratch that video I play
pretty terribly which is one thing but
then it was also deeply irritating I
started to think and then they started
to make noises outside of my place him
there has been problem with them it's
been a problem with them I'm searching
for a word yeah there was water leaking
outside some of the odds outside from
one of them like water drains or
something I probably not doing this
right not explaining it right but they
had some machinery going and it was
pretty irritating so I thought the video
was a problematic besides my pet play it
was just like probably just annoying
because of the background sound there's
still something going on but now we have
5:00 in the afternoon
it wasn't a big deal later actually
during the day anyway so here in this
game against ends none
we have a pollution that has been now
really that looks a little bit loose and
wonder if I should take and go i-5 the
let's let's open the Saab I know the
design bishop looks bad but I can open
up the position now the noise wasn't all
that bad during the day but during the
noon hours it was pretty irritating it's
still outside doing some stuff but it's
not as loud as it was ok I can't take
this I guess 94 ok didn't dare to play
that I can take here now right rook
takes 95 must be good and pawn takes 95
is probably not bad either
so I'm willing some material the
question is do a good be 5 here or not
yeah he's got Queenie fired but I don't
really believe in this
yeah I see no reason to give up on d6
pawn this looks very nice Queen h4 maybe
I have this phone hmm okay
luckily six let's look at it made its
treatment okay so please one this one I
think it's probably a reasonable
strategy
Sergi to just preserve every single game
:
and will seem at least a five minute
allows nature once in a while just sit
back and relax you in a five minute game
if you observe like intimidated sits
really bullish as we have 108
participants so I'm wondering why I know
I'm giving him lutely Mullane should
really be cautious I I came to get into
93 96 f4 which isn't great objectively
so for white but it's a bit of an
annoying line to face them like
especially F if you have no clue I
normally go Knight c3 Knight f6 which is
just better so f1 t5
okay here we get a normal mainline
Italian with c3 and d3
at least here I can move make many moves
quite quickly so interesting to see now
if he goes h3 so that this age 65 can be
put into motion probably not so to get a
trade on a son yeah all this is not
terribly exciting the Italian game is a
bit of a bit of a nuisance for black
somehow it tends to be yeah
it is not very threatening but it tends
to be very very stale somehow okay here
we treat to avoid 95 so I'm trying to go
here I forget I keep forgetting then I
have this opportunity with the arrows
during the game yeah neither falling
this doesn't really threaten all that
much but at least it looks somewhat
active
[Music]
I'm thinking about g5 I don't know how
good this is but with this time control
buzzer King you should try to to do
something and I just sit around it's so
easy to give wide submit wise the natal
f4 is an annoyance
you can play g3 but I have 93 and you
don't really want to take it only is it
the same what it would be what would be
good for him is to get in night somehow
to f5 or d5 introduce this possibility
to the position so a move like um um
beyond 94 for example could be an idea
white is taking quite a bit of time
there okay this is a very very
controversial move yeah where do I put
it it's also easy actually to say he
closes the center which in general
should help me because I'm already quite
well positioned to play some f5 break
turn it's about displaces for miss
places displaces is wrong miss places
mine and my night but 1975 is a good way
to activate it or more likely 97 to f6
Knight to c5 will probably always be
kicked with some Queen move and then
before so that is not as stable square
okay it's not really aiming for that
that that directly okay so take on what
I mean this is also making lots of
to get this on the half-open fan I think
I'll start with that because I'm not
sure that I want to take it for that
helps wide a bit yet to get his piece of
sorted okay I think I can just take I
have to watch out for the night on f4
which is kind of unprotected as there is
a leaf out pin going on the root ball a
seven is a funny piece and it just
covers this whole queenie three strong I
just saw it I just saw it and that's
very second he is a double he's double
attacking that frigging look into my
night hang so I blended a piece on my
god but hey what a terrible thing to
happen
yeah loose pieces him loose pieces and
of course he sees at him 1700 or not
here a spot blundered pieces okay
can I don't think it makes much sense to
resign I can still try to to irritate
them a little bit it's a full piece but
the time is somewhat equal ish now and
then maybe I can yeah whatever you need
a miracle somehow
he's very slow this is something that
I'm somewhat bathing my hopes on that he
might be a simply and not that he might
not be quick enough to get it some sort
of conversion but he's playing this very
well objectively speaking 90 46 of
saying he didn't turned and Knight h5 it
will take you know it's very very bad
[Music]
while I look before me as I keep
thinking about c5 here might be remove
it's a highly impractical decision
though
ways to slow the leaving speed up
and it was of course terrible which I
was rather instructive my rook was
unprotected and Queen III was a love
double attack I saw it this exact second
when we played it there just exactly the
same moment where you play pretty awful
okay hush 1,100
how does that happen and he gets me no
cause into a French defense might still
be a French at the end if it takes now
plays e-form
you just do it okay so I'm going to go
here and okay flattens b5 which is but
okay that's still not bad just expand
him well looks okay oh maybe cheek with
this and now it gives me the big sent
upon a for what's possible but I mean
what I play that thing was fine as well
but it will be at an Iranian it gives me
two pieces okay
thanks mate
it was a funny pairing okay so three
wins
even though well second game was pretty
embarrassing mm yeah
I never feel really good about those
time wins but I mean they play that
slowly release blow up at some point
call age 9 so ok yeah I think this is a
good line there there are couple of good
lines against this but Justin 4 is good
but I think inserting the check makes
sense that kicks a it leads to a fairly
one-sided game No
okay and chicken no Queen d7 is actually
not that grade what is best for
attacking less 'i'm ready now for for
the check yeah I should be able to win
by checkmate chef Queen D for Kings sex
food and I can probably just retreat no
need to do anything fancy here 94 and 95
are threats
Oh pre light or position at the moment
okay so I'm leaving by seven
yam won four games and seven points in
the process yeah so let's see what the
pairings are doing nothing happens at
the moment one hundred and fifty two
players not bad I think also many people
are going for the super blitz three
minutes time control which is of course
also also nice and I'm as irking every
game even though the sky is pretty high
rating
you should be formed is a bad line but
this is the kind of thing that can
irritate your lot with two minutes even
though two million thirty is okay what
is he thinking about him I hate this go
for it
I mean this is this is really bad
especially if he takes on you forward it
leads to complete madness castles or
Queen e7 are decent alternatives we flee
to a slight edge for white but nothing
too dramatic and also something that I
have forgotten sitting I studied it only
very recently nerd so Queen 723 is
survivor pilots that much I remember
castling short it's normal
and then I castle on Bishop takes Bishop
takes Queen ephod is good for y and this
is also good for ID but very in a very
simple manner just have the bishop there
for nothing here why this just better
and the better structure of course so of
course it is not something that where
black will lose quickly or anything it
just completely yeah completely awkward
game to play okay so question is like
before or not can also just play b3 you
should be three bag or so yeah I think
I'll make sure I go back
considering the time situation you could
argue that black is saying okay my
position is correct but you'll take a
long time to exploit that and with two
minutes on the clock you don't have the
time
maybe again objectively speaking this is
pretty awful so night here or three of
six I can first do what I need to do
anyway connect everything h3 at f4 is
the right way to do this I use soapy one
week before gauge for these kind of
things so also good
okay prevented anything direct here okay
that's a debatable move okay let's do
this again I have to watch out for the
time okay I have to probably do this at
some point anyway
so maybe regroup this 2c3 and go from
here I would also like to trade one look
maybe okay and this is actually looking
better okay so what is he going to do f5
so let's be ready to play g5 out of that
now here in some cases I can actually
think about trading off even on peace
because the H pawn is going to be
dangerous not it not so easy to do that
Bishop takes e5 I can do sometimes but
there's no real reason at the moment I
should try to get some pressure against
the F pawn that was almost certainly not
good giving me that pressure against the
depot
the chick only three but I just go king
of Qi why
well said already necessary now I can
just blunder through and the position
was very bad already but Jen it still
still would have taken some time to
convert some okay
so a couple of points ahead yeah I had
the one rotten game but the rest was
pretty okay okay
and slow I didn't play him before it
well that the guy who I had the problem
against Ike I don't forgive us
unfortunately okay so here we go for in
the Missoula and I actually do this okay
I will be three and three as well so we
get into into a same issue Kings say
mission famous revocation oh my god
pretty much uh it's a pretty clean
transition transition or transposition
probably both what's good work okay so
I'm going against the pawn to c4 pawn
it's not easy for what to do something
about it and every a bit skeptical about
the night g3 play here because it's very
slow
this night him attacking
okay so now d5 I just take so I don't
quite see how we cover c4 probably he
doesn't um I can go Knight d6 in this
position I think I will
it looks like a good idea trying to win
c4 without actually taking on d4 in the
first place yeah so here I can take on
this form probably like this also being
ready for potential d5 okay so I have to
take with the bishop and here yeah one
thing that I just noticed is that his
Queen does that many squares Bishop b3
will be 5 but I think this is very
simple and very very okay let's take if
he takes on c8 I could think about just
moving repeating my bishop way in trying
to Travis piece there but just taking
here is good and very very easy to play
this was the easiest thing in if he
takes night eggs I'm a full porn up and
not so really and not so difficult to
convert you or this scenario when my
night is just going to be a very strong
piece a lot stronger than this Bishop
yeah no backlink mate please page six
ideas a5 and b5
it's a little bit awkward that I have to
get rid of oh it allows me the services
very nice
now night Knight to d6 or probably
winders he only has rope the one to save
the pawn in the first place and I have
look here and then enter Roxy to is
pretty difficult to prevent or look-see
one if you place would be too so we does
not prevent it at all okay
you have how to actually windows and
threatening Knight f5 now winning
material okay he prevented this but I
can go here night-vision Bishop doesn't
have many good squares Bishop f2 Knight
f5 wins the piece yeah I kind of
expected it and it makes some sense and
b7 it serve is quick okay I can do this
though
look see 3d I go look b2 and I'm going
to take b6 we can now if you play and
play whoops c8 and look here but this is
very good
[Music]
you can almost pin with a three
mmm I'm not doing a bad job but you know
people chase me m-matt [ __ ] for some
real is closed I know it doesn't move
please please please play move
oh okay so those points helped and he
where he lost him they could have been
really close him okay so maybe good
pairing does help someone I'm not
getting higher here with no blips
reading good weird okay
see I'm mostly playing my classical
openings against you for at the moment
and just feel in those extreme extreme
or more extreme situations timewise I'm
best with my traditional stuff not with
the Alekhine's or some other more
controversial opening since that I have
some connection problems here I don't
know if it is my my internet connection
or there's something else going on
you never know where they again they
have worked quite a bit today around my
place and doing something with drains
and also I think with electricity okay
yeah very very much keep it simple
approach what white is doing here so I'm
trying something funny but I think it's
not so bad okay 94 or not hours truth
trying to bring the look oh but that's
not going to happen now I've to have
form okay
93 it's a very very simple idea yeah it
would be cool to get a page five and
really that is that looks very dangerous
this threatening look h3 it's already
pretty tough and therefore hangs as well
yeah this is the second idea
look at three threatening made into no
mate on h2 where's the threat Oh Jim dad
I was tough
after have fun
okay so nine points yeah with the loss I
think he has interrupted his streak
m-matt Koon it doesn't get as many
points points maybe GG m JJ and I'm
sorry is more of a threat still 11
points can almost pre-move a night move
here and could work with most of my
repertoire but let's see okay so we get
done Carol oops
b6
Jackie I can just develop her not c5 so
I will try to immediately punish me on
the kingside threatening to take g6 now
yeah that looks like the best relatively
speaking but how do you support this now
it looks like him yeah we'll create I
just take itself yeah this is a move but
it looks extremely weakening so how to
do this bishop here maybe I immediately
attack it and maybe immediately attack
it with this Knight takes d4 it's a
simple idea take the pawn and down hmm I
mean okay whoops g8 okay didn't want to
play g8 it seems I don't think it's that
that would have been so terrible I mean
relatively speaking okay just this is
good we need two pawns for nothing
cannot be all that bad okay hear me I
won't take care of it I think probably
just Queen e2 is strong attacking the
knight yeah now two pieces I
could have even taken the night actually
it would have been easier Bishop takes
takes on you seven winning winning a
full-piece with this as well that okay
this is not bad he will lose a piece
there's no way around that
No
let's just take this it's probably the
easiest
I will try to keep this pawn at least
for some moments okay okay I didn't
rework maybe am Bishop that seven
councils long for P 187 I mean other
piece up anyway
whoo
I'm going to promote ya inmate next
k-o-k 14 points net sounds comes to
also seem to I have fun managed to win
the most games I mean some of the
pairings seemed um helpful not same
JGM has also won most of the games for
all of his games baby but it didn't
deserve there that's up
it's amazing off like anything here
again this one yeah
as I mentioned this this is losing from
like is really losing but it's extremely
extremely wild and solving this all the
board can be tricky
this one actually who how does that work
should be age six
I don't know I don't remember anything I
mean like absolutely nothing is we okay
okay okay okay I'm back on track in 394
a before night c2 and Sonya okay
and I'm back on track they are 94 is the
only move that told any problem I think
we should a file fatigue on yes
hey I remember you take 25 Queenie 7 and
then Bishop d2 at the end them and you
get the piece back with a good very good
position Bishop f5 is the relatively
best move and now I think is it Bishop
takes probably makes more sense
okay King D 2 maybes well that's that's
giving me the piece s to go to g6 after
which why this comfortably better but
it's nothing terrible
okay um it takes this I'm probably King
III so I can just cover this porn for
the moment and then March maybe be fine
okay
excite preventing chicks
I've got the right bishop which doesn't
make with it it's neither
but it doesn't it is completely
irrelevant because I have no April
ah some call process I really kind of
kind of wacky can't just prepare the
Jeep and push
we came the a porn safely stopped can
maybe win the b-pawn on top okay let's
do over even with 15 seconds
so 17 points ahead that sounds good and
it should be enough s have a nine
minutes
17 points come on let's get one more
game in or maybe 2s la one's not really
placed at the top this is one of those
lines that people keep playing even
though they're absolutely bad the
problem is as white you never have it on
the board and you just never get it and
this sometimes again I've made a mistake
I have to play Queen e2 first uh-huh
yeah this is not fantastic for black
either but it is said so again and okay
I mean black can get a game here but you
shouldn't be as fine as he is now that's
what the bad create whisper to him okay
so okay
don't want em to trade this my
membership is pretty useless in
Knight to f4 is probably desirable so
I'm going here and then nine f4 I'm not
sure okay
I just take this have covered Duke with
good reason
King f6f for that that's not possible to
survive would be strange yeah I mean
look d3 look f3 looks devastating but
what is he doing after that can you just
play the simple not giving c2 up I mean
I could have taken on g5 I found the
defense it's so very nice threatening
look f3 again
what is he doing King g8 or something
but the look is also attacked the double
attack rook F 3 and the book Hales
yeah that's it more or less it's a win
at least purely position-wise it's away
oh okay until resigned
nice 22 points okay yeah one more game
me will be difficult to finish that game
but so nothing physics as well
funny so we essentially have a three
minute game okay so he build them stone
wall this
a5 is training mission a6 interesting if
five interesting
yeah so should be quite good quite good
for black
I'm head on the clock and it's a good
position just one now I continue maybe I
take and let's play em King g8 the play
f6 okay he's got nice c4 just just about
it was good actually hey the more I
think about it I have my doubts
okay well not okay
c4 is not easy playbook c8 next maybe
it's fine
hmm don't see anything good for him but
how do I actually make progress yeah
f6s was a threat okay I don't have to
worry about that he just gives me C for
now in d4 is also hanging so checking
all the pawns
ninety results okay so I got that one in
for 51 points at which so there are no
new pairings for this event so it's over
and I've won with 100% score yeah that's
nice look better than what I did earlier
yep I mean in this format the five
minutes tournament berserk in every game
is maybe quite valid I mean two and a
half minutes is still a pretty good time
to make somewhat diesels well not bullet
you'll get many points relief
yeah maybe here a ggm jgm could have
done something we hadn't lost the same
but okay catching up is difficult if you
win win the whole streak and I had some
cooperative opposition some opponents
were quite low waited and I could win
against those quickly this is a matter
of yeah luck with the pairings yeah I
hope you enjoyed the video trying to as
well thanks for watching bye bye